stiamo tutti dicendo che la consolidata
massima mors tua vita mea
e una delle più grosse idiozie che la
mente umana abbia mai partorito una
delle terra ci sta dicendo anzi ci sta
urlando che ad occuparci dell'ultimo del
più fragile del più minuto dei suoi
esseri non stiamo facendo un atto di
montella eroismo che stiamo soltanto per
seguendo il nostro bieco cinico e
immediato interesse
questo vale per una questione di cui si
parla dandole un nome errato i migranti
climatici ne tratteremo dal punto di
vista del nostro bieco immediato cinico
interesse solo che questo interessi
dobbiamo capirlo vedete in questa
dispositivo qualcosa che dia familiare
si chiama europa ma avete mai riflettuto
alla stranezza di questa idea tutti i
continenti sono delimitati secondo delle
barriere geofisiche secondo questo
stesso criterio noi siamo asia non
esistiamo
eppure vogliamo essere un continente
anzi il vecchio continente che cos'è che
ci caratterizza come qualcosa di diverso
dall asia diremo una cultura che nella
sua diversità una certa unitarietà
senza voler fare stupidi discorsi di
razza una certa omogeneità fisionomica
ma per qual è la determinante
fondamentale di tutto questo perché
siamo unitari beh la determinante il
clima l'europa è l'europa con una sua
identità particolare perché ha
beneficiato di una anomalia climatica e
intorno a questa anomalia climatica si è
creato il nostro congiunto di interessi
solo che le cose stanno cambiando
questa caratteristica climatica
dell'europa sto super semplificando ma
in qualche modo determinata dall essere
stati soggetti all'influsso
dell'anticiclone delle azzorre
che sta retrocedendo lasciando il passo
sempre di più a gli anticicloni africani
cosa significa questo significa che se
il clima è stato così determinante nel
forgiare la nostra identità i nostri
interessi
cambiando il clima cambiano anche questi
perdiamo la nostra identità europea
no a questa se ne aggiunge un'altra
noi entriamo anche nella comunità di
interessi che sono governati
dall'anticiclone africano
in questa prospettiva di interesse
possiamo cercare di capire cosa
significano per noi quelle persone che
sono mandate via dalle loro terre da un
clima che cambia e le rende meno
generose ma dobbiamo anche capire di
cosa parliamo
l'idea generale è che quanto più si e
poveri tanto più se propensi a migrare e
questo non è vero
i più poveri sono racchiuse in quella
che tecnicamente si chiama la trappola
della povertà hanno così poco la loro
prospettiva è di così corto raggio che a
migrare non ci pensano il loro problema
è trovare la ciotola di riso fra due ore
e solo quando si inizia ad avere qualche
sicurezza in più che si concepisce il
viaggio per andare lontano per
migliorare il proprio stile di vita
ebbene questi coloro che hanno un po di
base per concepire il viaggio almeno una
piccola dose di libera scelta di farlo
sono i veri migranti e se gestiti bene
possono anche avere un ruolo positivo
per se stesse per chi l'accoglie ma
questo è un altro discorso
il problema è che il clima che cambia
incide sulle vite di quelli che migrare
non potrebbero quelli che devono
andarsene semplicemente perché il campo
sia disseccato questi non sono migranti
questi fanno parte di movimenti forzati
di popolazione e chi è preda di un
movimento forzato di popolazione non è
utile se stesso non è utile a nessuno
perché anche preda nella sua estrema
fragilità dell'illegalità dei traffici
del terrorismo del fanatismo
cosa fa il clima siamo abituati a
sentire che il clima che cambia crea dei
fenomeni più estremi e più violenti e
quindi impatta anzitutto sulla nostra
fisiologia ondate di calore mettono in
difficoltà le persone più anziane si
stanno ampliando i cosiddetti reali cioè
le aree di incidenza di alcune malattie
infettive poi sentiamo anche dire che i
fenomeni climatici violenti fanno del
male alle nostre infrastrutture di
uragani che fanno crollare i ponti
eccetera eccetera ma quasi nessuno parla
del vero effetto devastante del clima
che cambia
che cos'è l'effetto serra l'effetto
serra è una porzione di energia solare
che viene introitata dal nostro sistema
e non viene rispedita nello spazio è
tanta la quantità è stata annunciata in
un altra tenda una decina di anni fa da
uno scienziato forse anche un po
controverso ma comunque dalla nasa james
hansen è l'equivalente di
dell'esplosione di 400 mila bombe
atomiche al giorno in che cosa si
trasforma questa energia che non si
incanala in delle strutture che si sono
formate nel corso di millenni si
trasforma in disordine si trasforma in
imprevedibilità lì dove il clima diventa
imprevedibile
le società hanno difficoltà ad
organizzarci se io sono un contadino e
non so quando pioverà
non so quando semino ma non è solo una
questione rurale se io sono
l'amministratore dell'acquedotto di
milano e non so se ci sarà neve o no o
dei grossi problemi a pianificare
ecco se succede da noi nella misura che
sta succedendo ancora riusciamo a
rimediare ma se succede a un contadino
del burkina faso
lì la questione più economica un mancato
raccolto per un contadino della val
padana può significare perdite
economiche ma forse sì assicurato forse
interviene alla regione per il contadino
al burkina faso fa la differenza fra
mandarono mandare i propri figli a
scuola
e allora diventa un problema di diritti
umani
e capiamo come una persona che è
sottoposta pressione sulle sue
prospettive di futuro sui diritti più
fondamentali della sua famiglia diventa
preda di migrazioni di fanatismi di
destabilizzazione di ogni tipo e
qualcosa per il futuro purtroppo no sta
già succedendo sta già succedendo in
delle zone che sono caratterizzate da
unico sistema fragile che si sovrappone
ad una società fragile sta succedendo
nelle isole che stanno urlando la loro
disperazione
le maldive stanno mettendo da parte una
par una porzione dei proventi del
turismo per comprare in futuro un'altra
terra sta succedendo nel delta dei fiumi
che si stanno realizzando sta succedendo
nell'artico le popolazioni artiche sono
la disperazione di manca tutto quello
che ha definito la loro cultura e si
trasforma in alcolismo si trasforma in
suicidi sta succedendo nelle montagne
particolarmente esposte e poi sta
succedendo
di fronte a noi il posto dove sta
succedendo più massicciamente al momento
attuale è proprio di fronte a noi ci
separa un breve tratto di mare l'italia
si distende fra le due sponde del
mediterraneo come se fosse un ponte
rimosso una mappa della porzione
settentrionale dell'africa è composta
per lo più di deserti che sono stati
deserti per lungo tempo
all'interno di questi deserti come
abbiamo ben capito questa mattina ci
sono delle popolazioni che hanno trovato
un modo di vita compatibile con questo
sistema quelli col sistema piuttosto
avaro solo che in questa zona non c'è
solo il deserto c'è anche una zona che
grossomodo coincide col sahel dove c'è
la desertificazione
se noi mettiamo su un piatto della
bilancia la generosità di queste due
aree il deserto la desertificazione in
termini obiettivi
l'area della desertificazione ancora un
po più generosa ancora un po più ricca
che non quella del deserto solo che
nell'area della desertificazione è
venuta meno la certezza dei cicli della
natura cioè il disordine di un clima che
non è più regolato e quindi non ci si
può più organizzare vi invito osservare
dove si trova e notare che coincide con
l'area di concentrazione della fame e
dei conflitti con l'aria di
concentrazione delle dinamiche
terroristiche con l'aria di
concentrazione delle dei traffici
illeciti di ogni tipo armi denaro droga
esseri umani e guardate un po da dove
vengono
nove su dieci di questi migranti che ci
stanno mettendo un po in crisi c'è
questa è la realtà per il momento su cui
l'italia nel suo ruolo di primo
protagonista stabilirà uno standard non
dobbiamo pensare che la cosa finisca qui
vi mostro due foto 1 una matta nella
prima mappa vedete la fascia degli
acciai dell'indo coach malaja e pamiro
questo un certo punto fonderanno non ho
il tempo di spiegare perché non
fonderanno gradualmente in proporzione
all'aumento della temperatura ci sarà un
certo punto un collasso i ghiacciai di
questa fascia a un certo punto
crolleranno ma noi che siamo italiani
che cosa ce ne importa per fatto che
ogni volta che si perde un elemento di
questo meraviglioso equilibrio che
chiamiamo biosfera o ecosistema non si
perde soltanto la sua presenza e
bellezza si perde anche la sua funzione
la funzione che svolge nel mantenere
l'equilibrio di tutto il resto gli
acciai svolgono molte funzioni
una di queste ci interessa molto sono i
regolatori di un ordinato deflusso a
valle di acqua dai ghiacciai di questa
fascia si dipartono fiumi che irrigano
piane ove sono stanziate un miliardo e
400 milioni di persone se i ghiacciai
crollano in questa zona che soprattutto
a sud e monsonica
la situazione nelle valli
improvvisamente passa da una in cui
durante la siccità ghiacciaio
sciogliendosi fa arrivare l'acqua quei
fiumi a una disastrosa alternanza di
siccità e alluvioni
significa che va in tilt all agricoltura
le infrastrutture e molto altro un
miliardo e 400 milioni di persone noi
abbiamo iniziato ad avere problemi con
l'arrivo di circa 380.000 persone
salviamo tutto questo che comunque le
montagne sono degli ecosistemi molto
fragili dove abitano popolazioni molto
fragile e si ma sono piccole sono
lontane non ho solo il 22 per cento
delle terre emerse e ci abitano a 913
milioni di persone se si mettono in moto
quelli e poi c'è un'altra foto mostra
una metropolitana allagata e a new york
l'innalzamento dei mari è una questione
molto controversa non si capisce bene se
sara tanto se sarà poco però ormai gli
scienziati avrete sentito parlare di un
recente rapporto del panel delle nazioni
unite considerano abbastanza plausibile
l'idea che aumenti di un metro e mezzo
entro la fine di questo secolo
aggiungete che il 42 per cento la
popolazione umana è stanziata lungo le
coste
se il mare si innalza di un metro e
mezzo ci saranno delle aree sommerse ma
non è tanto quello il problema è che
entra in gioco il cuneo salino l'acqua
salata entra nelle terre le brucia i
romani per assicurarsi che la città
sconfitta fosse completamente fuori
gioco sporgevano sale sui campi e questo
è l'effetto che farà vedo dai visi che
vi ho comunicato una bella kde tristezza
tutto è perduto no possiamo risolvere
possiamo risolverlo nel nostro bieco
cinico immediato interesse come
ricordandoci che siamo parte di un tutto
questo schema che vi mostro è stato
elaborato dalla fondazione barilla
mostra due piramidi la prima è molto
nota la piramide alimentare ci indica in
che proporzione dovremmo nutrirci di
ogni categoria di cibo per essere in
buona salute
quindi è poca carne rossa un po più di
proteine da altre fonti e via via
soprattutto fibre vegetali eccetera
eccetera
succede che se noi affrontiamo questa
piramide alla piramide dell'impatto
sull'ecosistema della produzione
ciascuna categoria dicevo coincidono in
maniera quasi perfetta
ciò è tanto più un certo tipo di cibo
consumato in eccesso non sono
vegetariano fa male alla persona tanto
più fa male all'ecosistema
accidenti che coincidenza spettacolare
nel settore dell'alimentazione
solo che non è una coincidenza e non è
solo nel settore dell'alimentazione è un
paradigma della nostra relazione con
l'ecosistema e non c'è bisogno di andare
a scomodare saggezza ultraterrene è il
frutto della co evoluzione e solo
normale che noi siamo in pieno benessere
quando ci poniamo in sintonia con il
sistema di cui siamo parte se non mi
credete provate a farvi un piccolo
esercizio la vostra piramide del
trasporto individuale e noterete che
quanto più la vostra scelta di trasporto
giova la vostra salute al vostro
benessere integrale alla vostra
socializzazione ritmi di vita tanto più
diventa sostenibile e questo vale un po
in tutti i settori ma perchè vi sto
dicendo questo perché questo ci dà una
pista ci dà una regola ciò che fa
veramente bene a te fa bene anche al tuo
pianeta
passiamo dalla scoperta individuale a
quella globale geostrategica se
l'occidente per magia decidesse di
nutrirsi secondo la piramide non solo
staremmo un po tutti meglio ma si
scardinerebbe la pedonalizzazione del
mondo fra miliardo e mezzo di persone
che soffrono di patologie per errata o
eccessiva nutrizione e 814 milioni di
persone che soffrono la fame
cosa significa significa che
sostenibilità
e benessere diventano anche giustizia
ridistribuzione si liberano quelle
risorse che sono consumate in eccesso da
alcune diventano disponibili per gli
altri con che potenza la calcolata un
professore di piacenza
se ciascuno di coloro che sono iscritti
come patologicamente obese nei servizi
sanitari occidentali si astenesse da
un'unica lattina di bibita gasata al
giorno creerebbe risorse per nutrire 56
milioni di persone quindi il mio
benessere individuale diventa
sostenibilità la sostenibilità diventa
giustizia ma la giustizia diventa pace
perché un mondo dove tutti i bambini
hanno accesso ad una nutrizione decente
anche un mondo che prende un po a calci
boko haram gli isis eccetera e quindi io
vi propongo questa equazione l'equazione
della terra se non discorso molto
individuale la mia scelta in armonia col
pianeta ma è un discorso politico
possiamo applicare questo metodo queste
mezze lune che avete scavate nel terreno
solo in burkina faso e sono un sistema
con cui possiamo recuperare un ettaro di
terreno desertificato a 130 dollari
facendo questo che cosa facciamo
riattiviamo per l'agricoltura questo
terreno ma creiamo un pozzo di carbonio
straordinariamente efficiente perché la
vegetazione rinasce non solo
proteggiamo la biodiversità consolidiamo
l'equilibrio idrico facciamo diminuire
localmente il calore perché la
vegetazione fa diminuire il calore e
riparte tutta l'attività il mercato
eccetera cioè noi scardiniamo il
meccanismo del fanatismo
il meccanismo dei traffici umani il
meccanismo delle guerre non ci credete
questo è il risultato vero se non lo
facciamo
cosa facciamo lasciamo questi paesi in
preda all'instabilità e questo significa
che loro non possono più collaborare a
recuperare il clima sono fuori dalla
gara comune per avere un clima che
ancora sia gestibile ma se sono fuori
dalla gara comune nessuno riesce ad
avere un clima gestibile per tutti
perché questi paesi contribuiscono con i
loro territori gestiti sostenibilmente
allora cosa fa succede se noi li
lasciamo in preda a se stessi tutti
quanti ci creiamo quel futuro che lighty
si si il panel delle nazioni unite ci ha
dipinto quattro giorni fa a 2040
la catastrofe è il solo il nostro bieco
interesse
dobbiamo occuparci dei più piccoli e dei
più poveri
grazie
[Applauso]